now I hope you enjoyed those new
episodes of scramble trust me
I Sully did thank you ladies relax
otherwise you have a girly pregnancy
bloody steamers got hot sauce everywhere
but there are some edge to bits I'd like
to show in fact they're scrambled
leftovers check this out
that has never happened
[Applause]
[Music]
where's the thing
Oh surely for God's sake I saw that
Batmobile you turned up in do you
sleeping that thing double bunk Oh
single bed actually the the second bunk
comes down from the ceiling when you
want it to right so you spoon regularly
then just sort of yeah oh it's great man
said it's a tattoo shop it's a podcast
studio it's it's an adventure mobile I
love it have you thought about the
cameras down when they're rolling in a
way that you just go with it yeah I
think they'd be there but us yes they
will be in the deliver gonna be right
there GoPros no filter on your hands
yeah I get in trouble with my fiance
should I meditate before caring for our
animals decent goats to go yoga these
these come in the house [ __ ] well they
don't they don't even know that they're
[ __ ] no they don't like they're just
learned it just falls out constantly and
they're walking around the big smaller
than face the chickpea salad I don't get
that bit I would be like the apocalypses
Martha Stewart if the world ended I
would be Martha Stewart
the most important part will keep that
pan same way okay good for you right
some people say they're not some people
say they are what's the answer
ya know they're super good whew what I
want to know in LA is whether my head
Jesus Christ emergency I was with the
Nutri Doris was back in Mexico and they
made me put the makeup on they made the
demands I took it back to my wife no way
she liked it she loved it I was fighting
with the Luchadors really and when you
see these wrestlers you think I got
pummeled I know they have to practice
routines mm-hmm
I'm the flipping over and the landing on
the back how did you manage doing that
when you came out of the cage with WV
are you transition the first thing you
learn in judo is falling yes so
following is literally first thing I
learned except for like we try to fall
and make it look like the other person
throws sucked right know if you follow
you're like trying to like arch out a
baby that wasn't anything was fine I got
thrown where is like WWE you try to make
it look as big as possible very dramatic
did you know at the time is going to
become that viral in a way that everyone
was like look at this [ __ ] I had a sense
that it would be popular but my concern
was what would be allowed on television
Lawrence you know like like yeah we deal
his crazy stuff but how much cuz they
really show yeah and and when the show
was initially picked up the director
creator Jeff tremaine's he said okay we
got it it's ordered now take all the
footage that you have and send it in so
then we can acquire it put it right on
the TV and I sent in everything that I
had he said sadly not one clip you sent
us is okay to show and I got like
worried like what what kind of a
watered-down wimpy ass show is this
gonna be sure that we found our way
around all their rules massively and and
and everything that couldn't show I you
know made it a career out of
distributing my own too hot for TV
videos yes and I did pretty well with
that for the people I was in business
with who never paid and those bastards
took out a life insurance policy on me
making themselves the beneficient
suppose let's say if it went tits up to
get paid they were like shoving me on
roofs inside trash cans and stuff more
died they would have got three million
bucks happening today
I bring chaos now when's the last time
you cooked a romantic dinner for fiance
what was last time you cooked that
romantic dinner for the entire breakfast
and when you propose her yeah I found
out how Travis proposed to Rhonda dead
animal New Zealand waterfall marriage
students and it's one of the most sort
of gory exciting proposals ever had a
grocer I was on stage and the taping of
coming special live I'm choosing the
audience on stage did you give the heads
up verb I couldn't believe no idea she
did even sense it she did have no I have
oh my god when you put it when you're
hanging over the side like that with a
handle this that's the hardest part once
it's there and the push in and just flip
it away so it goes there knit one
naturally just roll over get on the
handle don't tell anyone this by the way
I'm in there like that ready now it's
got a nice crispy yeah yeah let's do to
Hannah I broken both my hands this years
my arms like super weak like a little
t-rex blow this is I used to be sitting
on 22s but not anymore
this is like the gluteus my arm boys oh
stop it really
hi-yah [ __ ] ah small price to pay Gordon
crazy
[Music]
okay I'm gonna get there yep
xxx have narrow eye drops my favorite
have to be happy Gordon's thank you boy
why the season I think your seasoning
was more on point than joins unfortunate
later when I saw waste you squeeze the
linemen are right with the avocado line
no it's oh no it needed more salt right
needed a bit more so sometimes were you
texting too much you forget the
seasoning finer things
I should have salted you okay but yeah I
wanted to take the approach on this show
you took up there
Congrats man through the pleasure I
couldn't put Olivia culpo in a headlock
good i what's wrong with you Jesus
Christ you've seen our demos anyway to
depend four-year-olds whole spring
little word here we go let's do that one
together we gotta clean one no you can
believe it